y mucho
al igual que toda jordania
el agua es una gran fuente de
preocupación los antepasados eran muy
inteligentes al recolectar el agua
tenemos 38 reservorios podríamos
recolectar una gran cantidad de agua con
unas cuantas lluvias en esta zona
en la planicie de un el gmail la ciudad
antigua que ya tiene reservorios
con sus ruinas que se remontan a las
épocas nabatea y romana este pueblo en
la frontera con siria está situado en un
punto estratégico
el arqueólogo mofa casa nació aquí
de nuevo al antiguo sistema de
irrigación gracias a fondos
internacionales
estos arcos tienen 1400 años y hacen
parte de una cisterna antes cubierta
como pueden ver detrás mío están los
antiguos canales y el subsuelo acuático
es uno de los canales en vicentinos
cubrirlo va en contra de las reglas y
normas de la unesco entonces quedó así
sólo podemos limpiarlo y hacerle un poco
de mantenimiento le damos agua a la
municipalidad para irrigar los árboles
fútbol para que el pueblo sea más verde
el agua de lluvia es cuidadosamente
almacenada en este reservorio cuando
está lleno los niños de los alrededores
vienen aquí para aprender a nadar
el agua de su recurso escaso en esta
región desértica y la guerra en la siria
vecina sólo ha empeorado la situación al
lado de un animal esta atrae el mayor
campo de refugiados sirios del mundo
desde 2011 medio millón de personas han
vivido aquí en algún momento una
afluencia masiva de personas que
transformó el rostro de la región sur y
estábamos acostumbrados a tener agua
corriente a todos los días en las
canalizaciones el agua del gobierno
desde que llegaron los desplazados
sirios y como hay escasez tenemos agua
un día a la semana 12 horas al día en el
pueblo ahora hay menos agua y
enfrentamos un verdadero problema para
darle agua a la comunidad local durante
el verano
jordania es muy dependiente de su
vecindad
al suroeste de la capital el mar muerto
un recurso natural único por un peligro
para el 2050 el mar puede haber
desaparecido
a único lugar tiene un hotel a orillas
de este monumento bíblico
[Música]
el agua llegaba hasta aquí en 2010 en
2005 hasta ahí y hasta allá arriba en el
2000 promedio el agua retrocede en metro
al año y si eso se multiplica por la
superficie del mar que tiene 70
kilómetros cuadrados entonces no se ha
transformado en tierra firme si eso
continúa estaremos ante una catástrofe
ecológica
aislado el mar muerto sufre por el
cambio climático y la desecación de las
corrientes de agua que lo alimentan
israel y también siria están desviando
el tío cortando hasta el norte
el muerto es uno de los más salados del
planeta muy rico en potasio con walt le
reprocha al vecino israelí haberlo
sobreexplotado
sacan agua porque contiene potasio y la
secan al sol
normal son montañas blancas de potasio
para la exportación
medellín turno
[Música]
llamado el canal de los dos mares el
proyecto podría costar miles de dólares
el agua además se bombearía desde el
golfo jordano de aqaba y sería tratada
en una fábrica de desalinización el
proyecto podría salvar el mar muerto y
suministrarle agua potable a israel a
los territorios palestinos y jordania si
bien israel es un pionero de la
desalinización con su primera fábrica
abierta en 1997 en eliat situada justo
enfrente la ciudad de aqaba inauguró la
suya tan sólo 20 años después
[Música]
está la inicial
es la primera etapa de la desalinización
con un filtro de arena para remarcar el
agua hasta 50 micrones luego el agua
alimentará las bombas
un proceso complejo donde el agua de mar
es tratada con productos químicos antes
de ser transformada en agua potable 15
personas trabajan en esta fábrica que
produce un agua reservada para las
instalaciones hoteleras de aqaba una
contribución bastante modesta teniendo
en cuenta las inmensas necesidades de
jordania
debemos optar por nuevas tecnologías
como la desalinización para cubrir las
necesidades del país
necesitamos fábricas medianas o una
fábrica de gran capacidad sacamos agua
directamente del mar creo que también lo
hacen en israel en ascalón o en otras
fábricas de desalinización cuando se
está en el mar abierto de problemas de
recursos
[Música]
en una región destrozada por la guerra y
las tensiones son proyectos ambiciosos y
una fuerte cooperación entre los vecinos
podría resolver la crisis del agua